all the political parties are already
putting their spin on what's going to
happen on Thursday night here's our
guide to decoding their claims labor
claimed that the Tories ought to be
gaining seats on Thursday night given
that they did so badly last time Theresa
May had to resign not long after
why do you disagree there's still
um the largest party of local government
they're still defending the most seats
this time why might they lose seats
simply because where they are currently
in the National polls is lower than
where they were in 2019 in terms of the
national equivalent vote in 2019 the
conservatives and labor each got 31 of
the national equivalent vote and so if
the conservatives are now below 30 and
labor is above 40 it stands to reason
that there's a large swing from
conservative to labor since four years
ago and therefore for that simple reason
the conservatives will lose seats to its
principal opposition at these local
elections laborer saying a good night
for them would be them gaining 400 seats
how does that fit in the benchmarks that
you've done I think that's a very modest
claim and and given two things really
one is where labor currently is in the
polls it's at 43 percent so again if you
recall in 2019 we were saying that labor
was on 31. that's an increase of 12
percentage points on the position uh
four years ago so they should be doing
uh well and we think far better than 400
Gates really that's a very modest swing
from the conservatives to labor since
2019 they should really be aiming much
higher than that given what they need to
do to win the next general election
often you hear labor politicians making
the argument that these are not
elections happening in their heartlands
these local councils often Shire
councils not traditional places where
labor has a strong value how much
validity is there in that
that really
um if you like misses the point about
the the whole exercise of using local
elections to calculate a national
voucher because we take all of this into
account we're always comparing like with
like and in 2023 we will be comparing
with 2019 and for that reason
um it doesn't really matter where the
elections are because we're looking at
change in vote share and labor are Keen
to avoid comparisons with 1995 they say
you can't compare those two is that fair
for them to do I don't think it is fair
quite frankly and and the reason being
is that if we think about the context of
the next general election
labor requires a swing greater
than Tony Blair received in 1997 which
in itself Remains the post-war record
so I think it's reasonable to compare
with 1995 simply because labor in 24 in
2024 has to do better than Blair did in
1997 and then for that reason if labor
is doing much much worse than labor did
in 1995 then
um it stands to reason that quite
frankly that they're not in a good
position to win the next general
election now the conservatives are
saying that a good night for them would
be when you do your uh National estimate
of the vote that it comes out maybe no
more than six or seven points behind the
labor party and that would show progress
because that's much closer than the
polls uh suggest is that likely is that
a fair Bunch Mark to use do you think
that would be a good result for the
conservative party well if we think
about the national equivalent share from
last year it was 35 for labor 33 for the
conservatives so if there a Five Points
address then they've done worse than
they did last year this doesn't suggest
a party that catching labor up
necessarily but they will certainly
avoid the situation uh as in
1995 where labor was on 47 and the
conservatives are on 25 huge gap between
the two parties and of course labor went
on to win a landslide so I think the
conservatives need to be within touching
distance of Labor bearing in mind where
we are in terms of of the parliament
bearing in mind that a general election
is probably sometime next year there is
a limited amount of time for the
conservatives to catch labor up and
therefore they they really should be
within touching distance of Labor not a
long way behind the tourists are only
focusing on this a thousand seat lost
scenario are there more realistic
alternative scenarios that we should be
looking at for them you have to be in a
position where uh conservative losses
are inevitable
um but I think if they can keep those
losses down to say around five to seven
hundred they will feel that
um labor isn't really hurting them a
great deal
um and possibly also the liberal
Democrats who they are quite fearful of
in parts of Southern England like sorry
Cambridge uh Hertfordshire
um they too are not breaking through and
threatening conservatives uh at the next
general election so I think if if they
can keep losses down say below 500 they
will probably believe that they've had a
reasonably good night at this stage of
the parliament given uh the way in which
the current opinion polls have them
below 30 they will take that I suspect
and is it fair to say that labor
traditionally underperforming local
elections as compared to general
elections it is the case and our
projection that estimate allowed for the
fact that labor does perform rather
worse at actual local elections than its
current national opinion poll rating
suggests so we've take we've factored
that into our equation if you'd like and
um it allows the fact that the labor
leads over the conservatives uh in terms
of the overall asthma of the national
vote at these elections is not going to
be as great as the Gap that it has in
terms of the national opinion polls